there's a lot of talk nowadays about the
psychotherapeutic use of psychedelics
we're kind of going through a
psychedelic Renaissance it's been a
while since the nineteen sixties these
substances have been repressed but you
know mankind has been using and
experimenting with in Theo genacore God
facilitating substances for millennia
and there was a great essay written by
Timothy Leary that I think is fabulous
piece in the 60s called programming the
psychedelic experience in which he
defined the psychedelic experience as a
period of increased reactivity to
stimuli both from within and from
without so there's this increased
suggestibility it's almost like we we
dissolve the boundaries and the filters
that keep us from sort of being flooded
by sense impressions and so one is in a
kind of delicate suggestible state so
you wouldn't want to be like driving or
having to worry about crossing the
street with a red light or a green light
when you're tripping but the
psychotherapeutic use of being in a
state of increased suggestibility is
that if you pattern the input signals if
you sequence and control what you're
subjected to subjected to during this
period of of heightened sensibility to
stimuli you could steer awareness
towards useful spaces of mind you could
navigate that evanescent flux of
sensation and perception that Eric Davis
says is all we have and all we are
towards places of ecstatic illumination
the idea of being that you could grab
somebody and give them some high-grade
medical cannabis and then lead them on a
hike as they listen to the Inception
soundtrack and you could kind of curate
awareness you could steer the emotional
direction that people go to
we are mediated beings we are our
thought are our sense of self is
mediated by language its mediated by
environment its mediated by culture and
it's mediated by technologies like
cinema and music and so on and so forth
but we also are thick-skinned beings you
know a lot of the times we close
ourselves hedonic adaptation makes us
less sensitive to stimuli to the
mediation and so we create higher
resolution technologies you know 4k
cameras IMAX movie theaters to create a
more intense mediation that can thicken
that can scramble our defense mechanisms
and take us towards these useful spaces
of ecstatic illumination childlike sense
of wonder and so on and so forth but
those external mediation technologies
need to be accompanied by intern
mediation technologies that's what
Terence Mckenna used to say computers
are drugs and drugs are computers so we
need to have we need technologies of
inner space to go along with which the
technologies of the outer space and the
two of them together I think are pretty
cool because they allow us to experiment
with awareness with consciousness and to
kind of script or pattern subjectivity
Eric Davis one of my favorite writers is
the guy who talks about this notion that
what we're dealing with with these new
media technologies whether they be
high-resolution IMAX screens or
psychedelic substances is we're trying
to engage the technical material of
subjectivity itself in theory or 'ti
we're trying to harness and pattern
interior experience we're scripting
first-person awareness it's almost like
we become the director of our own movie
from our own POV and we get to take it
towards the place that we want we get to
experience the kind of evanescent sense
of sensation that we want and that that
ideas I mean it's totally out there but
how cool is it it's like it's this note
it's like reminds me of that movie with
Arnold Schwarzenegger total Rico where
you're able to kind of become someone
else by implanting the that's this whole
unfolding phenomenological experience
and so this notion that we could we
could just basically turn our minds
inside out you could pattern the human
imagination and sort of turn ourselves
into anything we want and experience any
possible experience is just something
that that sounds that sounds amazing to
me